انا مش مشاركين في
واردات الاسلحه
هل تضمن ان تذهب هذه الاسلحه الى الجيش
الاوكراني الذي يدافع عن ارضه ولا تذهب
الى السوق السوداء
هاي شي
مش بسيط
فاكيد هناك اتفاقيات واكيد هناك
بروتوكولات والى اخره وانا بعرف بينزا
تقريبا اكثر منذ من سنه على الاقل هناك
بعض من وفود من كونجرس الامريكي كان وفود
يزوروا اوكرانيا وكان حديث كان لقاءات
وكان بعض من خبراتون الى اوكرانيا لكي
يمارسوا يعني
يؤكد استعمال الاسلحه داخل الاوكرانيه
ووفق
للسحافه يمكن يهدس شيئا ما ولكن انا اتذكر
فقط شيء واحد لما
كانه كان
واحد يعني فنلندي في بحر بلجيكي ولكن انا
لست متاكد متاكد بين هذا مش صح كمان يعني
قوات اعلاميه من
الفساد في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وفي
صفوف الجيش بان هذه الاسلحه تستخدم للدفاع
عن الارض الاوكرانيه بايجاز انا شخصيا
متاكد بذلك فقط تستخدم للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا واما الفساد ففساد موجود في كل
مكان وحتى فساد في
الدفاع في وزاره الدفاع الاوكراني كانت
هناك اخبار بين
بعض من يعني اشياء حدثت فيما يتعلق
بماكولات المستورده والماكولات اللي تاتي
الى الجيش شكرا لك
على المشاركه في اخبار الساعه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات